how can I get rid of uterine fibroids? I have lived with them for a long time, was told
many years ago that they have calcified. I am not totally uncomfortable with them, but
I feel they may be the cause of a frequent urination issue I have. I currently use castor
packs on them and have been told that proteolytic enzymes would help. Is there any rife
program or protocol that can help get rid of them? Typically uterine fibroids, so a uterine
fibroid is a non-cancerous tumor in the uterus. If it is active, it can cause issues with size
occupied lesion. It can cause issues that the person is trying to get pregnant. It can cause
issues. The most common issue with uterine fibroids is bleeding. If a person has bleeding issues,
the uterine fibroids could be the cause of anidemia. It is not uncommon that a person with
uterine fibroids, if they get large enough, can cause anidemia. From a natural perspective,
how do you get rid of uterine fibroids? First of all, what are the causes of a uterine fibroid?
Most people believe that it has to do with imbalance in hormones at different times,
similar to PCOS, but that is just a debate. We don't know fully what they're caused by.
If they are causing anidemia condition, it's best to get them surgically removed. There is no natural
quote-a-quote cure for uterine fibroids. I have had people use the cyst program on the right
with some success. Some people have had no success with it. If the fibroids are not causing issues,
and again, the most common issue is anidemia because it's gobbling up ironed,
then you have to get them removed. If they're not causing any issues,
and you're not having anidemia, and if it's true, it is calcified,
then you might just leave it alone. I didn't even know if I'd even be doing castoral
packs on that area. You don't want it to become active. You don't want it to become growing.
You don't want it to be drawing iron and creating anidemic condition, because then it's a surgical
situation.